hello everybody and welcome to episode
11
no no 1200 stupid ah okay anyway welcome
to episode 12 of let's play black oh man
I'm Scott nevermind screw it screw it
I'm just going your crew intros it's
does stuff of nightmares man scarier
than this place all right where am I ooh
what's in here
nothing another close it there we go
there we go
all right how's my batteries
all right yeah yeah oh yeah oh oh oh
whoa get ready for a box
I'll boom ah you have a crowbar oh wow
there's so many oh no no no okay all
right this looks good
ah come on come on are you following me
fair enough
ah no on Oh so Manny oh there's so many
Oh God I won't budge
oh it won't budge no no bud no bud why
are they even there Oh
oh man see bullet hold forever in your
life God oh man
oh this is where I was I don't even know
I don't even know
oh man I lost okay all right that's fun
huh okay so as I've learned there are
multiple things patrolling the hallways
uh-huh eight monkey hey monkey oh I got
oh yeah I got a gas mask this is uh huh
Oh Oh No
Oh foreshadowing I love it
something terribly wrong glow stick
anything behind their barrels what I
didn't even do anything
box I think I think give me that box
oh shut up door oh you I'm gonna Oh No
there we go oh yeah and do a victory
spin okay Oh what else do we have here
okay
it's not open from here at all probably
probably all right okay
Oh something this looks kind of
important
maybe maybe um the thing in amnesia is
far-fetched that there might be one here
must be a way to fix it okay okay got
this just I'm hoping it'll feel I can
even just autofit wherever it's needed
just Zoop
Oh Oh No ah damn it
why did I do that oh uh safety lid on
the right ah okay do I have a saw shut
up it was a good idea all right
reinforced plating so I need something
hard core oh yeah
find something enough for the mask hi
all right bring it on you guys don't
scare me not even a little bit oh yeah
why don't we got ya nothing uh-huh
trying to be smarter about my flashlight
usage hey how about a milk jug you
bastard I didn't even facie oh oh oh
it's down here what's out here what's
down here oh hey won't budge
of course why would it budge oh oh
open ah there we go okay close close
close
all right goes block
ah go away I don't like you oh oh oh man
was he going away Oh is he going away
Oh tell me he's going away ah come on
yeah okay
all right yeah that's what I thought
didn't want to mess with me oh yeah he
is so stupid
ha ha you so stupid Oh fine I'm smart
I'm so smart okay that's an no budge oh
where do I go oh oh they're everywhere
oh they're everywhere oh I need a map I
need a map
I need a map okay Matt Oh tell me what
to do Matt oh I've been there I've been
chemical research laughs have they been
there I don't know I don't know I don't
know oh man uh-uh
oh no okay I need my hug
oh okay what my notes say those - a mole
a locked door in the chemical lab okay
fina find a keycard okay I was there and
I was there and pretty much every door
I've encountered is no-go on maintenance
okay I take go down this hallway and
then I yeah okay all right let's do this
bring it on I'll bring it on
don't bring it I'll break don't break
okay the archaic would never ask that
employees work longer than the
recommended eight hour shift but
understands that enthusiasm for their
work and dedication to the team may
often motivate them to do so aha thank
you for not letting us down huh yeah
you're welcome
what's in here anything in trash can
dump you out oh oh oh so smart I don't
even know what those are for but I got
one
all right there's nothing in here what
the heck oh do but just a thingy I don't
know I don't know what's down here oh
man oh man they're everywhere oh why are
they oh yeah okay where's this go all
right yeah all right bring it on uh-huh
yeah that's what I thought oh no oh this
is it Oh doggies oh no not that doggy I
don't have my hammer
I don't have my hammer oh oh no doggy's
a lot of flare proof that makes things
Lister oh yeah another strange artifact
okay uh Oh No Oh No
Oh Oh to jump on that is a synthesized
within the mine as a compliment you
can't control me you think I can conjure
up some white greenish how do you even
know what those are about okay yeah I'd
like that
it's hardly bad everybody it is more
interesting you probably just wasted all
of my Flair how dare you sir
I dare you what's behind here anything
what happened in here what do you mean
he's talking about Oh have it in here Oh
what happened in this hallway Oh what
happened in this box dogs oh no oh that
doesn't look good
oh I'm so boned oh god I'm boned
I'm boned doggie bloody boned oh I'm
screwed I'm gonna die a million deaths
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh my god
um okay
yeah turn gateun that's where the virus
came from small-scale epidemic epidemic
epidemic lost all control frisk and that
was like the leader oh boy
risk risk
oh no risk got infected huh
okay corpse
Oh No Oh his tongue was missing I
remember a tongue way back in overture
that I touched all right let me flip
this and I'll save the terror for the
next episode
oh they're part of the process oh then
I'm I should really stop touching them
then shouldn't I shouldn't I
I should but I'm probably not gonna do
all right thanks so much for watching
and you will see me scared like a little
girl in the next episode which is
episode 13 yep that's the one
alright thanks for watching bye bye